I will never say no to more Doctor Who
so at the tail end of the return of
doctor Mysterio we got this little sort
of teaser compilation thing of sort of
prepping us for series 10 and I wanted
to do a separate video giving my
thoughts on that
so this focuses largely on the new
companion bill now that is not uncommon
it's it's almost kind of a time-honored
tradition that this is a way to approach
sort of integrating a new companion and
when you tease the new series you tease
the new companion so we've gotten little
tiny glimpses more of her you know in
addition to what we saw from the little
sort of teaser clip we got before and
I'm not turning around on her yeah I'm
still I'm still open-minded I want to
see a lot of it
always with the companions is gonna come
down to chemistry brightening doesn't
matter - but the chemistry is the big
thing which is a big part of why Jenna
Coleman as Clara grew on me over time
because she had much better chemistry
with Capaldi than she did with Matt
Smith so I until I get a better sense of
her chemistry it's hard for me to make a
final call but the glimpses I'm getting
I don't love it's hard for me to
quantify what it is about it that isn't
quite working for me I I guess it's
they're they're hammering the she's just
sort of slightly off thing just a little
too much this she says you know doctor
what and she's asking all these
questions that are and I said this when
I did my video talking about that teaser
before and you can check that out if you
want to but you know the so the question
she asked about the Daleks or whatever
they they're not bad questions they're
not invalid questions and they're kind
of fun that somebody's asking them but
she's and she just sort of rolls in that
so much in that area it's just like
could you stop could you just kind of
like be in the moment and and do this
and unfortunately nothing I saw a really
dissuaded that a couple of things
reinforced it but it was more just it
swage the sentence that I got off of
that initial teaser and it also looked
like they used part of that clip in this
thing it's in this little mini teaser
itself which makes me concerned that
that wasn't sort of a little like
stand-up comedy routine that they came
up with to do in isolation that it may
actually be from an episode that
actually kind of concerns me I given
that thing a semi pass on the basis of
it felt like a comedy sketch I felt like
something put together exclusively for
the purposes of marketing and and and
teasing bill as a character and now I'm
worried that's actually from an episode
and I don't know how I feel about that
but nardole sticking around so that's
good we see the doctor smiling I'm
always happy to see that I mean if you
saw my review of the return of doctor
Mysterio you know I was concerned about
Capaldi sort of losing the fun that he
had brought in in series 9 I was afraid
that we're gonna go back to series 8
where it was much more serious much more
dour he was still good but it wasn't as
fun and I liked the doctor being fun and
the and he still has that in the return
of doctor Mysterio it feels like that is
going to still be the case here so I am
reassured by that it's and now I don't
want to harp too much on Bill but the
main focus of the teaser did seem to be
Bill and I'm still not sold on her again
keeping an open mind hoping to grow to
like her and ultimately will come down
to chemistry but that's pretty much my
main thoughts on this teaser I'm not
gonna like pick it apart frame for frame
oh there's this it's a Miss I mean
people want me to do that kind of thing
I suppose I could but I just wanted to
get more of a general impressions
general vibe that I got off the things
so the teaser series 10 what are you
excited for with series 10 what makes
you nervous about series 10 or whatever
it is drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter a council of geeks give a listen
to the council of geeks podcast
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned